was there a period of time where even
you thought you were a fluke like wait a
second okay yeah you know I wrote a good
movie here and I did you think it was
all gonna like go away and then they
didn't come a time or all of a sudden
you went holy [ __ ] I'm really pulling
this off I can do it the first thing
they actually got produced was the film
that I directed Reservoir Dogs right so
I wasn't like oh wow here's this writer
and now he's trying to be a director I
was BAM I was seen as a writer director
from the very beginning so then true
romance comes out right and they already
know who I am and they recognize the
dialogue they represent saying yeah and
same thing with Natural Born Killers so
by the time pulp fiction comes out I'm
actually a know at least among the
critics I'm a known entity right and
when pulp fiction came out dude and that
put you on the map it's because they
basically came out at the same time
oh yeah fiction in Natural Born Killers
and you were dead but that's my point
like you know it seriously then all of a
sudden you that's where you get your
confidence right and the pulp the
reaction of Pulp Fiction you go like hey
wait a second man I'm really on a roll
here and then every movie after that and
some doing really well there's an
expectation after that right by the way
Jackie Brown came out at the same year
as my movie came out yeah and Jackie
Brown did not win the Academy Award
private parts wasn't even [ __ ]
nominated one of the things about Jackie
Brown behind that was the fact that I
like dealing in genres and inside a
genre subgenres right and one of the
subgenres that I think Jackie Brown
deals with is the hangout movie right
and that's a movie where you get to know
the characters and then you are like
Dazed and Confused is a hangout mood
right you know aren't those movies scary
to produce because sometimes I get too
talky
right you can [ __ ] well that can
definitely be an accusation you can make
towards me with complete and dinner you
gotta be quiet because you can fall in
love with your own dialogue I don't
think it's I don't think it's a bad
thing but I mean my characters like the
top they sure do yeah yeah right you
know it's really though playwrights
never get accused of being talking
moving what they do well yeah cuz just
more exposition yeah you know but movies
is tricky movies can start to feel slow
right you got to play it just right
well yeah hopefully the idea is in least
in my case is your case yeah you're
creating rhythm yeah and you're sailing
on that rhythm and you're going with
that rhythm and you can break up the
rhythms and everything but that's what's
stopping it from just being a talky drag
and so now you got to go write this
thing yeah do you get charged up you
like [ __ ] I got to get this out of my
head this is gonna be all this is gonna
take months does it take months yeah six
months months do you get excited about
it or you just like ah [ __ ] well usually
the idea kind of is okay I'm thinking
about this and if it actually gets me to
start writing actually start writing um
is it torture it no no no not at all not
at all because I'm not sure 100% if it's
gonna work out or not you don't write it
in order to yeah you like it oh you do I
have to write it like you go scene one
well I don't want to know I really don't
know I don't want to know what's going
to happen in the second half I want to I
know how I were how I want to start it
off and I started off and hopefully be
have no idea of an ending well I mean
limply look I'm dealing with genre story
so I have an idea where it's going okay
at the end of Kill Bill I was pretty
sure she was going to kill bill but how
she was gonna kill bill and wasn't I
wasn't with me right like inglourious
basterds right like do you know I knew
it would I didn't I didn't know I was
gonna kill Hitler I didn't know that was
that fun yeah but I figured it would end
with a big mission do they have to stick
to the script or this some of these guys
try to ad-lib no no I'm paying them to
say my dialogue make no mistake wit and
I think we have to change these lines
it's not quite what my character would
say and you like get the [ __ ] out of
here I mean that could be a legitimate
thing that an actor says and if they're
right then I'll listen to them but if
they're but if they're wrong or if
they've just too lazy to learn the
dialogue and so they're gonna paraphrase
it no that's a can that is not gonna fly
yeah do you ever have actors you get on
set and they're not fully prepared and
they don't know their lines it has
happened it has happened what do you say
what a director what the hell do you do
then
well it's interesting all right because
I mean if it's a real real bad
case I actually I've never had a real
real bad case but better than that well
I had to drum an actor out in front of
the entire crew I mad you know you
really shouldn't treat adults like that
unless you can help I mean not you all
right but I mean but I shouldn't - my
actors that way